My name is Victor. Uh I'm a
Christian. Yeah. I have only one
question. In fact, thanks for coming to
Kenya. We appreciate you. I have only
one question to ask which is kind of
bothering me. Uh what's the difference
between your God and our God? The reason
why I'm saying this, it's because both
of us our prayers are being answered.
When the Muslim pray for when they maybe
they have a sick patient, they pray for
the patient, she gets well same as
Christians. So are we serving one God or
just want to know that the Bible asked a
very good question and a very important
question. He asked what is the
difference between your God and our God?
What is the difference between the God
of Islam and God of Christianity?
Correct? Yes. Because both of us pray to
God and our prayers are being answered.
If you think logically and
scientifically and spiritually, the God
of the Christians and the Muslims is the
same. There's no
difference. The God of all human beings
are the same. Whether he's a Christian
or a Hindu or a Jew or a Muslim or a
Sikh or a Pari, God is only
one. The God is the same. What is the
difference? People's understanding of
God is
different. God is the same.
Now Almighty God says very clearly all
the messengers that came from Adam peace
be upon him, Noah, Abraham, Moses,
Jesus, Muhammad peace be upon them all,
all of them worship the same
God. Correct? They bought the message of
the same God. But the people they change
the
message. When they change the message,
God sent a new messenger. and a new
message. Previously Abraham peace be
upon him came, then Moses peace be upon
him came. Then Jesus peace be upon him
came. Then prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him. All of them basically brought
the same message. The basic message was
believing in one God and worshiping him
alone. But the minor parts change but
the basic message is the
same. All believe one. But when the
messenger came, all the messengers that
came before the last and final messenger
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him, they
were meant only for their
people and for a particular time period.
For example, Moses was sent only for the
Jews. Man
is Jesus Christ peace be upon him. The
Quran says in Surah Imran 3:49, he was
sent as a messenger to Mani Israel for
the Jews. Jesus Christ peace be upon him
said it's mentioned in the gospel of
Matthew chapter number 10 verse number 5
and 6. Go ye not into the way of the
Gentiles. Go ye not into the way of the
Gentiles. Who are the
Gentiles?
Non-Jews. All those who are not Jews are
called Gentiles. Whether it be Muslim,
whether it be Christian, whether it be
Hindu. So Jesus Christ peace be upon him
said go ye not into the way of the
Gentiles. Don't go to the non-Jews.
Enter ye not into the city of the
Samaritans but rather go to the lordship
of the house of Israel. That means Jesus
Christ told to his disciple only go to
the Jews.
Jesus has repeated his message in the
gospel of Matthew chapter number
15 verse number 24 that I have not been
sent
but to the lost sheep of house of
Israel. So all the messengers that came
before prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him they were sent only for a particular
group of people and the message they
preached was supposed to be followed for
a particular time period. But because
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was
the last and final messenger. He was not
sent only for the Muslims or the Arabs.
He was sent for the whole of humanity.
And Allah says in the Quran in surah
amyia chapter number 21 verse number
107 that we have sent thee not but as a
mercy to all the worlds as a mercy to
all the creatures as a mercy to the
whole of humanity. And because all the
previous revelation four are mentioned
my name in the Quran before the Quran
came to zur and all that came before the
Quran they were meant only for a
particular group of people for a
particular time period but the Quran was
the last and final revelation because
there will not be any other revelation.
Almighty God protects it and says in
surah hijar chapter 15 verse number n I
have revealed the Quran and I shall
guard it from
corruption. You're listening to me
brother. Mhm. So because Quran is the
last revelation all the other revelation
that came before the Quran the Torah the
injil they have not been preserved in
the true form because they were not
meant for eternity. So Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala did not think it to preserve
it. But because Quran was the last and
final revelation, Allah takes it upon
himself to preserve
it. All the messengers that came before
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him. They
were not meant for
eternity. Jesus Christ never said peace
be upon him, go to the Muslims, go
everywhere. He said go only to the
Jews. So that's the difference. So now
you ask him the question what is the
difference? There's no difference. The
problem is your prophet Jesus peace be
upon him told as I mentioned to the
sister earlier in gospel of John chapter
number 16 verse number 11 to 14 I have
many things to say to you but he cannot
bear them now for he when the spirit of
truth shall come he shall guide you onto
all truth. He shall not speak of himself
all that here shall he speak he shall
glorify me. This is prophet Muhammad
talking
about the coming of Prophet Jesus
talking about coming Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. Day after tomorrow I'm
giving a
talk prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
in the Bible in detail about his
prophecies in detail. So why don't you
follow prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him? So the almighty god is same. Allah
says in the Quran in surah Imran chapter
number 3 verse number
19ah and Islam the only religion
acceptable in the sight of Allah is
Islam. Islam means submitting of will to
god. So your god and our god is the same
god. But most of the Christians say
Jesus is
god and then that god died on the cross.
How can I believe God died? You may not
be saying, but most of the Christians
say God was in hell for 3
days. Jesus Christ peace be upon him
went to hell for 3 days. How can I
believe God can
die? So God is sin. But your version of
God is different. Our version of God is
chapter number 112 verse number 1 to4
which
says saying Allah one and only Allah
Allah the absolute
eternal he begets not know he's
begotten there's nothing like him this
is a fourline definition of almighty god
any candidate you say is god if that
candidate fits in this fourline
definition we have no problem in
accepting that candidate is God. For
example, do you believe Jesus is God?
Okay, let us put him to the test of
suras Allah. Is Jesus one and only? He's
not the only man who claimed divinity.
The country where I come from India,
there are thousands of men who have
claimed divinity. Number two, Allah.
Allah the absolute eternal. Was Jesus
Christ peace be upon absolute eternal?
Yes. Was he absolutely eternal?
You know the Roman poked spears correct?
He died. He's not absolute. So he cannot
be
God. He beates not know he's begotten.
He was begotten to mother Mary. Correct.
So he cannot be
God. Nothing like
him. We know Jesus Christ is like human
being. One nose, two eyes, two hands. He
cannot be God. Suppose some lunatic man
tells Prophet Muhammad is God. No Muslim
will say that. But suppose a unitic man
says prophet Muhammad is God. Let's put
him to test.
Correct. Is he the one and only? There
are thousands of men who have claimed to
be
God. Allah was prophet Muhammad absolute
and eternal. No. He went to t. He was
stoned. He bled. He had to eat food.
Right or wrong? So he cannot be
God. He begets. Not know is he begotten.
He was begotten.
He had a mother by the name of Aina. His
father's name was Abdullah. He had
children by the name of Fatima. By the
name of Ibraim, he cannot be
God. There's nothing like
him. So if you put to test of
suras is the true definition of God. So
the problem is your God and my God and
all human beings God is the same. You
have misunderstood the meaning of God.
you are worshiping a false god. So if
you're worshiping a false god, you have
to search for the truthful God. As I
said earlier, there is not a single
unequivocal statement anywhere in the
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself says that I am God or worship
me. If you can point out, brother, I'm
talking to you. Yes. When I'm talking,
don't look down. Then what is the sit
down? You ask me a question. Yeah. You
have to look at me. You cannot read and
listen to me same time. Can a person do
two things 100% together? Yes or no?
Yes. Two things you can do together.
Yeah. Yeah.
100%.
Yes. Two things you can do. You can do
Yes or no? Yes, I can do. Very good. You
can be in India and be at the same time.
No, you can do half. If you are reading,
you can understand me 100%. No.
Yes. If you're reading something, you
can understand me 100%. Or maybe little
bit here and there. Ah, no. I can't
understand. Yeah. Now you're speaking
truthful. Thank you, brother. I was not
hearing. Ah, that's okay. Very good.
Thank you. If you make a mistake, say
sorry, no problem. Don't argue like
that, young kid. Correct. So, I agree.
So, when you're asking me a question,
you pay attention. I'm giving the answer
the answer. Dr.
Where is the
answer? So if you ask the question,
everyone is listening. Correct? And
you're not listening. Is it correct? I
was writing down what you are saying a
bit. Huh? I think no, no problem. I'll
repeat it. So I'm telling you there is
not a single unequivocal statement, not
a single unambiguous statement anywhere
in the Bible where Jesus Christ peace be
upon himself says that I am God or where
he wor or where he says worship me. If
you can point out from anywhere in the
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself says that I am God or where he
says worship me. I Dr. Zakin Knight am
ready to accept Christianity now.
[Applause]
challenge.
No. Very good brother. Brother say, I
hope so. Hope you realize the true
concept of God and I pray to Almighty
God that may you really worship the true
one
God and you're very logical and I pray
to Almighty God to give you guidance to
search for the true God. Thank you
brother. I love you. I love you for sake
of God.